I couldn't get any sleep last night
there was something scratching from
behind the walls it's probably his rats
or something probably get it checked out
tomorrow
couldn't sleep again last night
damn scratching sound came up again this
time it was all over the place like it
was scurrying through the walls and
ceiling I seriously have to call someone
about this that damn scratching won't
stop I called over the landlord and an
exterminator they gave my room and the
entire floor thorough inspection sort of
knocking through the walls they said
they couldn't find any evidence of pests
anywhere well [ __ ] them at least the
inspection was free [ __ ] hell
still there I borrowed some plastic
ceiling spray from one of my neighbor's
I'm not sure how he happened to have
several cans of the stuff lying around
it just seems a little bit too
convenient from the way he acted it
looked as if this wasn't the first time
he'd done something like this maybe no
just my imagination and in sleep that
night I spent the whole time stealing
every possible crack and hole in my
apartment I don't want to risk that damn
whatever it is crawling into my room
[ __ ] I think that thing must have crept
in while I was out I can hear it
scratching around on the inside of my
room now god I think it's coming closer
soon to my head eating my thoughts it's
not my edit in my thoughts in my head
it's my head in like hostage it's in my
head and you knew my thoughts semi-hard
know it's in my head thoughts in my head
it's a my head eating my thoughts it's
in my head
it's in my head heart
all right subject his/her folk occasion
male cause of death unknown at this time
but look at him he's actor I know you're
new here but please refrain from making
unprofessional statements during the
autopsy
severe trauma in the top half the
subjects skull scratch marks on the
wound suggests that the trauma was
self-inflicted
and on my hand the blood skin hair and
bone fragments found under the subjects
fingernails correlates with his
hypothesis he scratched his own brains
out that's a very blunt way to put it
but yes that seems like what happened
doesn't it yeah okay now Nautica never
be too sure that's continued